what's not to love when it comes to
lumpia crispy and flaky on the outside
juicy and tender on the inside it's
truly a party in every bite whether you
enjoy this popular filipino finger food
as a snack or main course lumpia is a
total crowd pleaser at any family
gathering so from our family to yours
we're excited to share our favorite way
of making lumpia the word lumpia
translates to spring roll in several
languages
it's evolved from many asian cultures so
there's a variety of ways to make it
traditional fried lumpia usually refers
to shanghai lumpia or lumpiang shanghai
it's the most popular version we also
think it's the easiest one to make
lumpiantoge or sometimes spelled toge or
lum pyang gulai is fried like lumpian
shanghai but the roll is bigger it's
served with white vinegar mixed with
garlic onions and black pepper the
filling usually consists of vegetables
like julian carrots bean sprouts sauteed
pork shrimp or both fresh lumpia also
known as lumpian saliva or lumpiang ubud
is not fried but wrapped in something
like a crib this version is typically
filled with meat but can easily be
vegetarian or vegan like this one it's
commonly served with peanut sauce and
topped with crushed peanuts now turon
isn't considered a version of lumpia by
everyone we think this can pass for
olympia but it's sweet a saba banana
which closely resembles a plantain
is wrapped in a lumpia wrapper with
jackfruit and sugar then fried you
probably guess which version we're
making today we're sticking with the
classic lumpian shanghai when it comes
to selecting a protein for our lumpiang
shanghai we tried pork
chicken beef and even plant-based meat
substitutes some people add shrimp to
the pork we love this combo so if you're
into it go for it just make sure to
coarsely chop the shrimp today we're
going with ground pork don't worry about
cooking your meat prior to wrapping if
your meat is pre-cooked it will be
harder to wrap because it won't bind
with the other ingredients
the meat will cook during frying the key
to a good filling are balanced flavors
and enough vegetables to keep our
protein moist and tender in our recipe
we're using carrots sweet onions and
water chestnuts water chestnuts are
going to give our lumpia a nice crunch
and moisture you can chop these
vegetables on your own or simply throw
them in a food processor and pulse
just don't puree them they should look
like this
toss this in a bowl with our ground pork
and add some thinly sliced green onions
garlic
soy sauce nor seasoning
sugar
black pepper and a large egg that's been
lightly beaten we recommend using a fork
to mix everything together to avoid over
mixing over mixing or filling can make
the meat tough then cover the bowl in
plastic wrap and pop it in the fridge to
chill for 1 hour
time to talk wrappers you can make your
own lumpia wrappers if you have the time
but store-bought lumpia wrappers from
your local filipino or asian market are
great options and more convenient lumpia
wrappers are often referred to as spring
roll wrappers but don't confuse them
with fresh spring roll wrappers fresh
spring roll wrappers or rice paper are
thin like lumpia wrappers but they're
clear and typically not cooked we
recommend using the standard traditional
9 inch round loom pair wrappers
be sure to pull all the wrappers apart
before you start rolling this will help
speed up the assembly process to keep
your wrappers from drying out cover them
with a slightly damp towel or plastic
wrap so they don't dry out if you don't
do this the wrappers will fall apart as
you roll them
the last thing we need to do is make a
slurry
this acts as a glue and keeps our lumpia
intact when it's fried egg wash also
works we did a test with just water but
found that the wrappers unraveled to
make the slurry combine a bit of flour
with water and now we're ready for the
fun part place a wrapper on a large work
surface and spoon five tablespoons of
the filling inside you might think the
more filling the better here but it's a
delicate balance the wrapper and the
filling have to complement and support
each other like a pie crust to its apple
filling and corn tortilla to its babil
now when it comes to rolling it's a lot
like rolling a cigar or a cigarette fold
the bottom half of the wrapper on top of
the filling and push and tuck the top
half onto the filling roll the filling
forward away from you then apply the
slurry onto the top edge of the wrapper
and roll completely to seal and we did
it it's that simple in most filipino
households you'll get an army of people
to help you with this part
so recruit friends or family when you're
making these
we promise they'll love it once rolling
is complete we would like to cut them
into smaller pieces
we found they are easier to fry this way
but you can definitely leave them long
either way they'll taste great now a lot
of families like to freeze them to fry
later for a party or a quick dinner or
snack to do this set them on a sheet
tray in a single layer not touching and
freeze for about two to three hours once
frozen
transfer them to a sealed container and
you can store them in the freezer for
three to four weeks max however we want
to eat them now so it's time to fry in a
heavy bottom pot pour canola oil until
it reaches one inch high and heat until
reaches 375 degrees fahrenheit once it's
hot enough gently place some lumpia in
the oil don't overcrowd the pan you want
to make sure they cook evenly let them
fry for about five to seven minutes you
know they are ready when they look like
this perfectly golden brown
set them on a cooling rack lined with
paper towels to absorb any excess oil
bring the oil back up to 375 degrees
fahrenheit to ensure they get just as
crispy man this smells like our family
birthday parties when i was growing up
we'll keep doing this until all our
lumpia is fried
when it comes time to serve lumpia would
not be complete without a dipping sauce
lumpy on shanghai is often paired with
something that is both sweet and tangy
like banana ketchup sweet chili sauce or
sweet and sour sauce so pick whatever is
your favorite and it's time to dig in
grab one of those flaky rolls of
goodness
generously dip it in your sauce and
enjoy we hope you give this recipe a try
and let us know in the comments what
your favorite kind of lumpia is to find
this recipe and many more visit
tasty.com
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you